concerns in the report which is highly
unusual
secondly it has proven especially
difficult to secure a minister before us
we do appreciate your appearance today
but it must be said that for matters of
such political legal and constitutional
significance it is incumbent on
government to be proactive in its
engagement with select committees and
more generally the house and in relation
to our very specific standing orders
effective scrutinous Hallmark of good
law and improves rather than hinders its
its achievement
thirdly the timing and sequence of UK EU
level events have been an ongoing
concern to us as we warned in our report
only last Tuesday the withdrawal
agreement joint committee will meet on
Friday to agree The Winds of framework
this is only three days from our session
now and two from the storm won't break
statue instrument debate which is
tomorrow
we will consider the sis and its
appropriateness later that there appears
to be no good reason for this artificial
timeline which sees the government
signing off a tax published weeks ago
with no change
we were promised engagement but the
government has failed to deliver
anything meaningful
this impromptu session and tomorrow's
90-minute vote on approving an SI is all
we will we will have had it appears
clear to us that the government set its
course weeks if not months ago and has
done all it can to avoid being diverted
from it
The Windsor framework is a significant
development in the UK's post-brexit
relationship with the EU its legal
complexity speaks to this and there's a
vast amount of paperwork as you know and
its Provisions would impact the people
and businesses of Northern Ireland and
Great Britain it is therefore deeply
disappointing that we find ourselves
here today
on the content of today's session we
will cover timing sequence and scrutiny
of the Windsor framework and related
matters
the framework itself including the storm
won't break applicable EU law in
Northern Ireland the European court of
justice vat state aid and red and green
Lanes
domestic policy and legal implications
and next steps so before we start
perhaps you would like to say a few
words Secretary of State also Mr Davis
and Mr thrillfore perhaps you would also
like to introduce ourselves thank you
very much thank you Jim and
um thank you for the invite I I I
completely understand what you said but
um about
getting some getting the Prime Minister
before you but he does go before
uh a committee of this house on a
regular basis for an overall uh hearing
on all sorts of things however when you
contacted me at the weekend
um as a long-standing former member of
this committee
um I was I'd like to think you felt that
I was delighted to accept your
invitation I was very glad the fellow
may say so that you responded so rapidly
and um and I am genuinely
happy to be before this committee uh
today I know this was as you say hastily
arranged and um and forgive me uh for
not having
as much time as you you might possibly
like to go through all these uh all
these matters
um however
um I I am joined
um by uh well Davies and Brenda
thriftful
um I've certainly said that wrong I'm
like three thoughts
um who are like I guess as a football
referee um I've got mitrovich and Silva
uh either side of me they've been I'm
from the cabinet office and involved in
this for a very long period of time my
primary objective as Secretary of State
uh for Northern Ireland is to get the
Northern Ireland executive and the
assembly up and running
um the day-to-day application of the
protocol as it currently stands has
meant this is not able to happen at this
point
for a very good reason that everybody on
this committee will know the Windsor
framework represents an important
opportunity for a turning point for
Northern Ireland the framework protects
the economic rights of the people in
Northern Ireland and provides us with a
basis to move forward together as one
United Country it deals with the
everyday issues that people and
businesses in Northern Ireland had faced
as a result of the operation of the
protocol we have Rewritten the protocol
treaty and replaced it with a radical
legally binding New Windsor framework
something many said could not be done
the agreement removes the Irish RC
border and restores the free flow of
trade from GB to ni through a new Green
Lane it gives the people of Northern
Ireland a veto over new laws that apply
there and protects Northern Ireland's
place in our Union through fixing
practical problems including on pets
Parcels medicines and ensuring that UK
decisions on tax and spend benefit
people and businesses in Northern
Ireland as they do in Great Britain it
goes further than the July 2021 command
paper
and protocol building crucial areas and
restores that delicate
balance inherent in the Belfast Good
Friday agreement and importantly brings
stability for business
the committee will be aware that we have
begun the process of domestic
implementation of the framework as you
as you mentioned with the draft
regulations giving effect to the storm
won't break and I very much look forward
to taking your questions and to set out
why I believe these new Arrangements
will have delivered on what the
government's set out to deliver and be
to be the best outcome for Northern
Ireland and the UK as a whole thank you
very much
it's actually a state for the questions
because you only have a shortage time
with us as you appreciate it and you
just mentioned uh so for the questions
that we don't manage to cover will you
commit with your army of officials if
I've entered it that way around uh to
answer them in writing and commit to do
so before tomorrow's vote if we send
them to you after the session is
finished I'll do well absolutely do my
best I'm the Northern Ireland office
does not have an army of officials but
I'm sure the cabinet office has a um
some spare that can help I was thinking
much more about the oh and Todd grouping
of the government machine behind this
it's been going on for months I will
endeavor to get you that reply it's very
kind thank you very much so what is the
Windsor framework because the public I
think probably would like to hear from
you and why should MP support it when
the UK has left the European Union but
the citizens of Northern Ireland are
still being subjugated to EU law yeah I
mean the Windsor framework
um well as I hope I said in my opening
remarks that um The Windsor framework
actually involves a fundamental a bunch
of changes to the old protocol uh one
which many in this particular committee
voted for I voted uh for and establishes
entirely new arrangements for UK in
internal UK trade in a deal that tries
to identify the full range of issues
that Northern Ireland has been coming
under over the last two years
um
there's an element uh so as I said the
secretary state for Northern Ireland
there are some significant issues uh and
the everyday delivery of Public Services
to people in Northern Ireland which are
being exacerbated by not having a
functioning executive or assembly um
that is sitting and I know that the
reason for this is well articulated is
that the Practical issues of the current
protocol are causing uh great
disturbance amongst one particular
Community the unions community at this
point in time
so the Windsor framework is a
a way of trying to address those
concerns amongst that community and all
all communities in Northern Ireland
because I met with every party leader on
a number of occasions in Northern
Ireland and they all have certain issues
with the current functioning of the
northern line protocol some obviously
want to see it
maintained in in a very similar state to
the where it is now others wanted
these new
fundamental change those practical
issues just so we can
so I can highlight them for you where
gradually as the protocol got enacted
and remember it's not been completely
enacted at this point
various Goods started to disappear from
the shells of shops and supermarkets in
Northern Ireland GB companies were
choosing whether for good reason or bad
not to supply Northern Ireland because
of issues with the Northern Ireland
protocol various Goods various goods
were actually almost prescribed by the
current functioning of the of the
protocol and for those of us based in GB
you can hear this on you don't need me
to demonstrate this to you because if
you listen to any advert on Commercial
radio that's advertising are good it
will invariably say at the end of it in
the financial small print
this thing is not available in Ni
so every day uni unionists were quite
rightly questioning whether they were
being pulled within pulled out of the
orbit of the UK internal market and
pulled with into the orbit of the EU
single Market
businesses in Northern Ireland and lots
of them
um
also wanted to maintain the access that
they had to the European single market
and I'm I've had letters from numerous
Northern Ireland MPS asking about how
this could be maintained in the right to
this process
uh one was contacting me saying the big
uh concerned about what the outcomes
might be would there be dual regulation
in the future and I had a letter from A
Member of Parliament outlining the the
Austria Farmers Union have raised those
issues around dual regulation because it
would have to run essentially two lines
for each product that it was producing
in a massively increasing its costs
um and that that MP
um uh wrote to me highlighting those
concerns
but equally highlighting that businesses
interest in maintaining its access to
the European single Market as well as
the you've made that point and I'm very
grateful to you because we've got so
many questions yes absolutely like I
said I don't want to cut you short but
on the other hand we have got a lot of
questions to ask so I was going to ask
one more question which is of course
section 38 of the withdrawal agreement
act 2020 enables the Northern Ireland
protocol to be overridden by the
Northern Ireland protocol bill so why is
the government stated it is withdrawing
it
um because uh the legal basis for the
bill has fallen away with this
negotiated settlement
as detailed by
um
the the legal statement that went
alongside this well I know there's been
a lot of comments about this the basis
of necessity which was a which was as
you know being tested by some yeah I
think it's fair to say it was being
tested rather than trashed it was being
tested
um by uh various lawyers and indeed the
European Union itself European
commission itself but the basis of
necessity
um has essentially been removed by the
new Commons it did pass the House of
Commons unamended and it reached the
House of Lords and at the moment it's
sitting there like the Mary Celeste in
the House of Lords
um marooned be calmed and it's now being
stated in your papers that is going to
be withdrawn although you can't withdraw
it wouldn't be withdrawn as you and I
are probably two of the few people as
far as a former Chief whip of the
government
um I was pleased to be able to deliver
an unamended Bill all the way through
the house of the House of Commons
process
um and I watched it as it was gradually
uh entering the very calm Waters that it
it faced in the House of Lords um
obviously uh you don't bills don't
really get amended until they've gone
beyond committee stage in the House of
Lords I think it would be fair to say
that the bill whilst and whilst now
currently in pristine condition
possibly wouldn't have come back from
the House of Lords in in that space But
that's what the commons is there for to
uh sort that out but but the basis for
the bill is essentially gone because the
basis of necessity has been removed all
right so I'm now going to move to uh
Greg Smith please thank you chairman
Secretary of State uh good afternoon I'd
like to probe a little bit around the
definition of sovereignty because when
making his statement on the Windsor
framework on the 27th of February the
Prime Minister spoke of how the
framework will and I quote Safeguard the
sovereignty of the people of Northern
Ireland now it's a relatively simple
soul I Define sovereignty as whereby
laws are set
by the country that they cover where the
highest Arbiter of those laws are
National courts we can see from The
Windsor framework that even the
concessions that clearly are in it are
done through amendment to EU law as
opposed to any national law so can you
run us through what what is actually
meant by safeguarding the sovereignty of
the people of Northern Ireland well I
mean and actually thank you for
um spotting that there has been
um some positive movement
um I know some might judge it as not
enough but I don't think when the Prime
Minister introduced The Windsor
framework he did state that it was not
perfect
um
but actually uh from I would I would say
from from the point from which we came
this is a massive massive Improvement in
um how things will operate for Northern
Ireland he also said
um and this is uh as I was making clear
to the chairman
um that because of the land border that
Northern Ireland has with the island
itself
um
and because of uh
us wanting to ensure that we protect our
UK internal market and the European
Union ensuring it wants to protect its
single Market
and businesses in Northern Ireland
manufacturing businesses in Northern
Ireland wanting to maintain their
current access to the European single
Market
um that we spent a lot of time talking
to and listening to various businesses
and and groups about how that can best
be dealt with
what this does this deal does I'll come
to the sovereignty point in a second
what this does is it strips away
um
hundreds of pages of displays hundreds
of pages of EU law as they apply to
Northern Ireland at this point
um it's about I think it's 67 different
laws that you're talking about that
anyway there are I could make it a lot
more pages if I increase the font but
it's um it strips away lots of that but
it does maintain
some aspects about three percent re uh
just under three percent we reckon of
existing EU lawyers it applies through
the Northern Ireland protocol
at this current Point
um uh it does maintain that which is
what we believe is the bare minimum
required for that free-flowing access to
the European single market for
manufactured goods in Northern Ireland
um the sovereignty point is that um I I
I've had I mean lots and lots of
comments from different people
over a long period of time
about where the current protocol has no
actual Democratic input at all people in
Northern Ireland not having any say over
the laws that affect them and how they
how they feed through the system what
we've done is introduce the Stormont
break which I know we'll come on to
later
which does effectively give people in
Northern Ireland a say over those
remaining EU laws that new laws that
come in are mental laws current laws
that are amended
it does give them a say over over those
and whether they should apply
to Northern Ireland in the future and
the ultimate Act of sovereignty is that
actually
in a year's time in just over a year's
time the north 9 assembly on a majority
vote could vote to reject the whole
thing
itself
just coming back very briefly on that
point because I'm conscious of time is
the and others will come onto the stone
on break specifically later is the clue
not in the question
that there is no UK legislation or
indeed anything that storm on could pass
that enables any of the concessions that
we're talking about here
it is EU law itself that has to be
amended to allow for the green Lanes Etc
and to allow for the storm on break
therefore meaning EU law continues to be
Sovereign over Northern Ireland with the
greatest of respect and what we are
doing in the house tomorrow is uh we are
passing a piece of legislation through
this house to enact part of this deal
doubtless there will be other future
legislation and indeed there'll be
things that will doubt the slow um from
joint committee and Beyond but
um this is uh there's agreements on both
sides of this and uh and indeed
um I would say compromise on both sides
okay colleagues will come into that in
more detail can I just ask one slightly
different question about the statutory
instrument that we have 90 minutes
debate on and a vote tomorrow in the
House of Commons going back to the 27th
of February when the Prime Minister
announced the Windsor framework he
talked of parliament having
they say over the Windsor framework
tomorrow we're looking at a very
specific part of it the Stormont break
there is some speculation that
tomorrow's vote is actually being
considered as the whole say over the
entire Windsor framework a a meaningful
vote if I can put it that way on the
whole deal what is the government's
official position on the vote that we
are being asked to take part in tonight
it's the factual position that this is a
vote on the SI that activates the storm
won't break I believe Mr Davis just
wanted to come in very briefly it was
sorry was just on your previous question
because it's probably important to
clarify several of the and in fact
important elements of these changes are
not made
through changes to e-law so the storm
Breakers are changed at the treaty
itself so we're using the uh changes to
the withdrawal agreement text uh
similarly the v18 excise rule changes
they're sort of done through changes
that are tricky so these are there are
various elements of that kind which are
actually made through changes to the to
the withdrawal agreement itself not to
changes to
um to EU law and obviously there are
elements of the Customs Green Lane that
we're talking about there is set out in
the Joint Committee decision which is
part of the discussions that the chair
referenced on on Friday at the
withdrawal again Joint Committee
so my last question is when will the
House of Commons and Parliament have a
say on the whole of the Windsor
framework as we've said from the very
start from the 27th we're going to give
and I'd like to think this has been
demonstrated by action people time and
space to consider everything that we are
doing here I think and I think this
storm break is
um the it's really important that we
have this in place
sooner rather than later because there
has been a lot of speculation as to what
it does and what it can't do how it
works and how it can't work and this
codifies it in black and white so people
can actually see it for itself as a very
important part of that Democratic check
that your question started out on as a
former Chief whip um I mean I know
they're going to be future opportunities
um in in on some of the things that Mark
said and uh future sis and Parliament
will always find a way if the government
doesn't allow it to have it say and I'm
I'm generally not particularly worried
about that
thank you uh Grand Davis please your
chair um now the European Union was
adamant said it wouldn't
renegotiate the Northern Ireland
protocol uh quite reasonably because
obviously that's signed in international
law which trumps both EU law and
national law so why do you think they've
agreed to make these fundamental changes
do you think it's because it helps the
peace process helps the single Market
helps inward investment perhaps helps
U.S investment why do you think they've
changed their mind when they didn't need
to
um I think it does all those things that
you detail but I don't think the
European Union changed its mind because
of that
um the opening mandate that the European
Union had when initially negotiating the
protocol was to protect the Belfast Good
Friday agreement when you see one of the
key institutions from one of the strands
of that agreement not functioning
um I mean you can ignore it for a
certain period time but it was obvious
it was not functioning because of the
way that the current protocol is working
in Northern Ireland
and so
um you know I would love to say it was a
fantastic negotiating skills by a team
of brilliant negotiators on the on the
UK side that persuaded the EU to make
the treaty changes and it was obviously
by again but
um actually I generally think it was
because
the uh as as the 25th anniversary of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement uh was
materializing on the horizon and
understanding that actions
I always say that when this when the
protocol was written when we all voted
for the protocol I know you didn't Mr uh
Davies but uh I think pretty much the
rest of us did oh are you abstain I'm
sorry
I'm in favor of the protocol yeah yeah
but I'm just I'm just saying that um you
know
I don't think anybody envisaged the
Practical effects that the day-to-day
operation of even the bit of the
protocol that is now working has on the
people of Northern Ireland and certainly
wouldn't have on it didn't have that
understanding of what it meant to the
unionist community
um and so I think it's a general
realization of the importance of the
peace and stability that's been brought
about by that agreement but on that
point then do you think enough has been
done to persuade all political parties
in particular the dup and what's in it
for them because I've got to say from
where I'm sitting it seems to me there's
a lot in it for the dup in terms of
inward investment jobs peace you know
the United States putting more money in
British companies perhaps moving to
Northern Ireland and finding it
difficult to trade into the single
Market in a 50 rather trading less or
none at all so there's a lot of economic
benefits and stability benefits for
Northern for the dup but have you put
enough effort into talking to the dep
about selling the the benefits that have
been negotiated with the consent of the
EU
um I would
um
I mean I so I I would I I try never and
I've always done this throughout my
course career to second guess what other
political parties might be doing because
I'm not wired necessarily in that
particular way but I do think there is
how would you sell it to the dup that's
I think I think so I think actually the
Windsor framework
um as it um comes to the fore with the
storm won't break enacted
um and indeed some of the other things
that we need to do because the the
darker units party had
seven key tests that it was testing what
the government was trying to achieve
against lots of them covered by I would
say what we've done in the Windsor
framework but some are actually more
fundamental uh than that because there's
um
there's the act of Union piece that is
fundamental to any unionist and the cons
and potentially the concern as to
um constitutional Arrangements in the
future I would say that
um I I truly believe hand on heart that
this deal will bring better more more
Prosperity better uh to Northern Ireland
and when you have more Prosperity I
think um nations are highly unlikely to
want to change their uh their
constitutional setup I think
um prosperity and in fact I think like
almost semi-quote paraphrase the leader
of the democratic unions in uh party
um but everybody wants prosperity for
Northern Ireland and if we get this
Prosperity piece right I think that
helps guarantee the union for decades
generations to come and do you agree
this hard wires economically Northern
Ireland into the United Kingdom because
if there is more inward investment we'll
get the tax and we're not going to give
up Northern Ireland as part of the
United Kingdom in any hurry so do you
think that's a strong argument for the
dup to consider I I believe there's a
case and I believe we will be trying to
help codify some of that as well okay so
just moving on
many of us see that the whole of this
Windsor framework work is being rushed
without submission consultation and the
facts speak for themselves
the government announced yesterday that
the UK EU withdrawal agreement joint
committee will meet on Friday to sign
off the Windsor framework and this will
be after members debated draft statutory
instruments on the Storm outbreak
tomorrow which aside from this session
will be The house's only formal
opportunity to engage with the
government on the deal
so will you agree
will you agree that the Windsor
framework comes into effect in the wagc
on Friday that's the first question
our elements of it dude yeah so why does
the Windsor framework have to be agreed
on Friday
um so elements of it are part of the
deal is actually there's a whole host of
sequencing of of different events but it
is actually the 10th meeting I believe
of this joint committee this is uh it's
not a a new thing it's just an evolution
of the Joint Committee and what it does
they're pretty big the step in the
evolution I should say but what is the
rationale for the timing of the SI vote
tomorrow and then followed by the
wagc on Friday
um the rationale for the I think I
detailed the rationale for the SI timing
and
um I honestly don't know why the joint
committee is sitting on Friday but the
Joint Committee sitting on Friday I
believe it is
I mean some would argue very strongly
that this is rushing the process when
you notice the deal nearly a month ago
after at least four months of secret
discussions with the EU I mean we were
not aware of what was going to happen
until we saw the papers immediately
before the prime minister's statement
yeah I'm not going to apologize for
um people conducting negotiations in
confidential situations because that's
what businesses do and that's what we
should be doing as a government
and I think now having published
um everything on whatever it was the
27th of March
um I'd like to think that we are giving
the people the time and the space to
critically go through
all aspects of this
so Craig McKenzie would you like to ask
the next question you think you're just
on to the uh the storm on break uh you
said in your Preamble uh this afternoon
that it allows a veto for the people of
Northern Ireland now just let us expand
on that a little
um it only applies in some quite limited
areas it's only uh can come into play if
there is amended or replacement EU law
so not all the old stuff as it were it
doesn't apply on issues relating to
state aid vat exires most of the Customs
code trade defense or the electricity
market so I think we have to accept that
that broad use of the word veto is
perhaps a little expansive compared to
the truth it has fairly narrow use
and there was a test that has to be met
and that test and I'll quote it is it
would an issue would would have a
significant impact specific to Everyday
Life in Northern Ireland in a way that
is liable to persist now a couple of
questions arise out of that who
interprets the word significant is an
interesting point
um perhaps you would like to start with
perhaps refreshing your thoughts on the
use of the word of a wide wide-ranging
veto and who decides what is significant
or not MLA is decide 30 mlas would
decide what's significant
um and uh there is a veto at the end of
this process through in Joint Committee
okay but you you do accept it's got
fairly narrow scope across those areas
that are specifically excluded and it
only applies to new or amended EU law
um so it applies to new or so it does
not apply you're quite right to the
existing body over you law that
currently although lots of that as I've
said is disapplied but to the three
percent of EU law that still kind of
flows through the system there is the
bare minimum for access to the European
single market then for new laws or
amended laws in that space it does apply
mark would you like to just step in and
no no are we still waiting for this list
of the laws that won't apply and what
three percent will of course we're
completely in the dark about those which
would have been helpful for tomorrow I
would have thought I think I think it is
worthwhile saying um it does it applies
to
um the very significant majority of
things that are in Annex 2 of the pro
article of the of the existing vertical
and what will be the Windsor framework
that is that includes uh a significant
amount of the of the rules that you're
referencing there it doesn't cover some
of the ones that you're talking about
but in some of those areas we have other
mechanisms so there are other sort of
forums for discussion but I think it's
just important to note that um the the
scope of this applies to the very
significant majority of good Goods rules
and those are the areas where those kind
of impacts we're likely to see in
practice so that's that's the reason for
how the how their break is defined I
think I just add to that Mark as well it
does I think you mentioned the Customs
code it does apply exactly the entire EU
Customs code yeah and that's actually
listed there the the whole
um the whole Customs code is valuable so
the break bytes on any amendments and
Replacements to that where the where the
conditions are
okay let's just put our minds forward a
bit I'm I'm certainly hope will you be
able to confirm to me at Secretary of
State uh that the retained EU law bill
is still on track to make its Passage
through this place
it was last time I checked good okay
let's just pass put our mind forward a
bit
if and when this place agrees to retain
to you law bill and we then have can we
go when yes when thank you good
um we will have the opportunity to do
things that are right for a you know
global trading nation that the UK always
should be
but what that does mean is that 48 years
worth of uh accumulated EU law can be
investigated changed and ended discarded
whatever we might please
um obviously Secretary of States have a
lot of powers within that no problem
with that but of course that retained EU
law Bill all those years worth will not
apply to Northern Ireland we will not be
able to use the retained EU law Bill to
disapply stuff
to Northern Ireland because we've got a
set in stone date
which is
departure day for us we haven't had to
apply the last three years worth of of
new Corpus of law that's coming out the
EU Northern Ireland has had to have that
whole 48 years worth plus the last three
years and yet its only ability through
the storm on break is to perhaps after
this quite circuitous route let's let's
be very clear of the application of the
storm on break can actually prevent
future law on trade matters applying to
it so does the retained EU law Bill make
an even bigger Gap a glaring gap between
GB and ni let's see if we can just apply
the last 48 years worth they cannot
um
I'm afraid I'm going to push back quite
hard on how you describe the storm on
break
um because it is not Securities it is it
is a very very
straightforward way that elected members
of the legislative assembly sitting in
uh Stormont I mean yes that there is a
clarification there Mr chairman you have
to be Stormont has to uh go back for
this to uh come into effect
I'm afraid you probably need to have
someone else in this suit to
um oh How likely are mlas like um handed
across to Northern land to decide
whether they invoke this
what are the chances realistically of
that ever happening I don't know you
have to ask the members of the
legislative assembly but that goes
doesn't that go back to the point was
was making that that is that is a point
about sovereignty and if members of the
legislative assembly choose to to use
that their sovereignty then they
absolutely can 30 members of the
legislative assembly from two political
parties
could be from one traditional others or
none at all can through
activate the the break and then a whole
essentially a process starts that just
applies EU law and we can and actually
could be vetoed in joint committee
forgive me from a German
Secretary of State
um you must mentioned the sovereignty of
Northern Ireland which is a real problem
because Northern Ireland doesn't have
sovereignty it's Westminster it has a
sovereignty I mean which is why it's
Westminster that would
um enact The veto
it is why this government it would be
the UK government that would not DeVito
in the joint question we'll come back in
on that now so well just just to I mean
the point came up that was quite
interesting just last Friday and that
was the uh private members bill on the
hunting trophies import prohibition bill
and yeah widely supported across the
house all parties certainly something
that that many of us would support uh
that that should apply in across the
United Kingdom and the right honorable
member for East Antrim asked the the
minister the the the member for Copeland
about why that will not apply the the
trophy Prohibition in Northern Ireland
now that's a pretty small bit of
legislation hugely totemic supported by
this house and I'm I'm I can but assume
supported by most people in Northern
Ireland and yet because of the ongoing
attachment to the single Market rules
and trade rules under the EU it cannot
apply in Northern Ireland now now tell
me in all honesty does that sound like
sovereignty does that sound like this
Parliament acting on behalf of all of
the peoples of the Union of the United
Kingdom I think um and I completely
understand the point you're making
um on this issue and you are right that
you know this should be able to apply to
the whole of the United Kingdom but
um the law as it stands that the vast
majority of people in this room voted
for
means that that is not the case
The Windsor framework and the Windsor
framework goes to solve new EU law
differentiation and we'd have to change
various things in the UK internal
marketing and other places for uh uh
unfettered trade to become a reality
from Ni to GB
um but I don't think it does solve this
particular individual issue
um because it will be part of those
three percent of EU laws that apply
um for the bare necessity that apply for
uh applied for the access to the single
Market
um and therefore but if it were to if
there was an EU law that was to change
in this space then the the storm break
could come into effect but I think
that's the honest answer that individual
case of a small bit of law to technical
as it is doesn't that highlight the
difficulties of when we have the
retained EU law bill that increasingly
might change some of these matters and
also in that to me shows how the re UL
will not apply to Northern Ireland in
the way that we may wish so actually I
mean so this is a because it's a new law
that it's actually you know it's a new
bill that is not actually a
so and
um my illustrious colleagues in defra
are looking at how they can make this
apply
um in Northern Ireland going forward but
I just on the I didn't answer your point
and forgive me about the retainer you
law bill and I don't think it is the
case as you suggest because I I've had
plenty of submissions uh advising me how
difficult it would be for the Northern
Ireland civil service to go through the
body of retained EU law in Lawton
islands in the situation without an
executive up and functioning on
ministers uh there uh for for them to do
that so
um either they're doing a body of work
for no good reason or the retained EU
law bill uh will apply Brennan sorry
yeah I was glad I think on the retain
the law but it's important that
obviously applies to the whole body of
retained EU law uh that's in UK law but
that includes for example a vast amount
of rules that will apply in Northern
Ireland and everything from immigration
to financial services to procurement to
data how we regulate artificial
intelligence to I mean we could we could
go on and we can we can set that out in
more more detail but all of the changes
to that we retain to you law will apply
either UK wide if it's a reserved or
accepted function or if it's in the
devolved space then we will you know
ministers here will legislate for
England and then it'll be up to devolve
demonstrations I'd like to move on now
because we have here from north charland
um who is a member of parliament in the
United Kingdom Parliament which does
have the sovereignty a grateful Mr
Robinson if you kind enough to ask the
next question thank you very much to
Chairman good afternoon Secretary State
and to your colleagues Secretary of
State before this evidence session you
were quoted publicly as saying that the
storm and break would give members of
the legislative assembly the final say
on the application of EU law and this
afternoon you suggested that members of
the legislative assembly have a veto on
the application of New York amending EU
law do you accept that that is not the
case no because of the way we are
codifying what a minister has to do in
the in the joint in The Joint Committee
um I think the the process is
is pretty much um straightforward I mean
there's a commitment that the government
cannot agree the government cannot agree
to the application of a rule in The
Joint Committee unless it has a vote in
in the assembly across on a
cross-community agreement or it doesn't
impose a new regulatory border within
the United Kingdom or exceptional
circumstances and I know people have
looked at exceptional circumstances and
thought what could they be and they
could be something like foot and mouth
or some sort of State there are and I'm
across the detail of the storm and break
would it not be more honest to say
that there are exceptional circumstances
in which the government can exercise
their vote irrespective of the view of
elected representatives in the Northern
Ireland assembly
that's what Article 15 provides in this
tournament break and it gives
government ministers UK government
ministers their choice as to whether
they exercise a veto or not would that
not be a more honest assessment than
suggesting that the storm would break is
more than what it is
um
to disagree with the honorable gentleman
perhaps would be helpful if you'd
outline what you believe
exceptional circumstances
therefore deliver to the UK government
Minister who would be in The Joint
Committee yeah I can exercise that part
without recourse too or taking account
of the views of assembly members is that
not correct but there will be a binding
statutory obligation in domestic law
on ministers to trigger the break when
these conditions are made it would be
unlawful for ministers to refuse to
notify the European Union that the break
is being triggered because they're
concerned about whatever it might be
potential EU remedial measures under
Article 13 4 of the framework and so sex
secretary said both those aspects are
right they are there in the Storm at
brain but that does not lead anyone to
conclude that it offers members of the
legislative assembly a final say or
indeed that they have a veto
would you accept that
the actions of the members of the
legislative assembly directly lead to
the government's to The veto
um directly in need but they do not hold
the veto
can directly lead
to The veto secretary said you've
indicated that you would need to see the
restoration of the institutions at
Stormwind for the storm and break to
apply which section of the SI indicates
that
I think that's um it's made clear in a
sort of international law text that
we've agreed in terms of the conditions
so
um that is an obligation you know that
was part of the operation of the break
that was agreed as part of it and that's
an important reflection for us about how
it should operate as in it is putting
power in hands of the elected
institutions installment so um that is a
that's an international law condition
around the use of the break and it's
also reflected in the fact that the
government can make a notification under
the SI only where the conditions in both
Article 13 3A and the unilateral
Declaration of met and one of the
conditions of the lateral Declaration of
the institutions are functioning so it
flows through that provision we know
there are
volatilities within the institutions in
Northern Ireland are there circumstances
in which the break can be used when
storm is not sitting yes once the
um it cannot begin to operate until the
institutions are back and running there
after it's if member if the members
seeking to use the break are looking to
operate the institutions in good faith
and I think the tech sets out conditions
like seeking to nominate ministers and
support the normal operation of the
assembly then it could be used so those
are conditions that are in the in the
text of The Joint Committee decision and
then that flows through into the SI as
well
Secretary of State you you know that
this SI is entitled The Windsor
framework Democratic scrutiny
regulations I think you've already
accepted the there is more to the threat
of Divergence
in Northern Ireland than just EU
Divergence there is UK Divergence yet
through this evidence session we
understand that tomorrow's vote is the
vote prior to the adoption of the
Windsor framework on Friday
so can you give a sense to this
committee what else
we should expect
on the operation and interoperability of
law in Northern Ireland and how elected
representatives from Northern Ireland
can guard against future Divergence in
which every direction it may come yeah
and um and what Mr Robinson is
articulating is that actually the a lot
of Provisions in the UK internal Market
act
um were not applicable for in in the
Northern Ireland context because of the
operation of the protocol
we would need to uh look at that I
believe can be done
is that right through
yeah I'm being I'm being factually
correct here so yeah I think we're we're
the Prime Minister committed to saying
that we would uh strengthen the
provisions then there's a a back story
here where in uh 2020 the government
removed some Clauses from the then UK
internal Market bill for Northern
Ireland's uh businesses access to the uh
to its most important Market in the rest
of the UK irrespective of of any
differences across the
um across the United Kingdom and the
Prime Minister committed to now to
restoring
um similar Clauses in the UK internal
Market act which we can do and we can do
now in in compliance with international
law and then we've also set out of
emotions in the uh in the UK
government's command paper including
um using and strengthening the role of
the office for the UK internal Market
which is already there to and has a
statutory role to monitor
um the risks of Divergence within the UK
and make sure the UK internal Market
functions in a smooth way and just one
further Point Mr chairman which I know
is important to Mr Robinson and quite
rightly so
um but the in the government legal
position that was published alongside
the Winds of framework documents
um on the 27th it um the legal position
states that the Windsor framework
addresses the government's position is
set up to in the July 21
come on paper it respects the acts of
Union and the Belfast Good Friday
agreement and deals with the everyday
issues people in businesses in Northern
Ireland have faced as a result of the
operation of the protocol in protecting
and goes on to say in protecting the
economic rights of the people of
Northern Ireland ensuring that just and
equal treatment for the identity ethos
and aspirations of both communities
um and whilst that's a lot of words I
think it's actually quite an important
statement when it comes to the union
moving forward it's an important
statement Secretary of State that's
right but in the last preceding number
of months the government have argued in
the UK Supreme Court and before that in
the Belfast high court and court of
appeal that article 6 has been impliedly
repealed
are you constitutionally and
legislatively satisfied that article 6
of the acts of Union is no longer
impliedly repealed and if so can you
share that advice and the legal advice
says that we the The Windsor framework
respects the acts of Union and so
um that's quite a different thing
Secretary of State yeah and I know do
you have legal advice on whether article
6 of the active Union remains impliedly
repealed or not because you'll know what
the equal fitting Provisions are and
you'll know that whilst you can argue
categorically that there is progress
through the Windsor framework
you cannot categorically say that people
in Northern Ireland through all of these
issues that have been raised thus far on
Divergence and different legislative
framework and on requirements for the
movement of goods that we'll come on to
and all the rest is an equal fitting
so
I can only refer because it is the
correct place is to the government's
legal position on this that was
published alongside these documents but
as the uh as Mr Robinson knows
um there is more work a foot to try and
make sure that the clarifications can be
made in both law and and other ways as
we move forwards to make sure to put
this issue where it should be to bed one
final question in this section chair
before I know Mr Johnson Mr Fish want to
come in
um secretary said you'll know in article
14 there is a provision that precludes
the validity of notification
um precludes a minister from considering
remedial action from the EU as a reason
for not accepting the validity of
notification
you will have heard people previously
say a minister will never exercise a
veto for fear that there would be
retaliate reaction and at least on the
notification
and the validity of that notification
that is explicitly ruled out in this SI
why does it not feature an article 18 of
the SI on the exercise of vote at Joint
Committee
um
I don't know the answer to that question
I mean I think I think as you as the
Secretary State set out I think what we
have provided that is a very significant
set of safeguards
um at each stage I think the duty on the
government as you make clear in
paragraph 14
is there to ensure that there aren't
irrelevant factors considered in whether
or not the break is triggered if mlas
make a valid notification to the
government
the government is bound to notify and so
that is enshrined that is a powerful
Safeguard and there is also a very
powerful Safeguard in terms of what
happens when the UK government makes
decisions that the Joint Committee which
are as as the chair made clear are sort
of matters of ultimately of
international Affairs within the
um within the sort of sovereignty of the
of the government of Parliament
that we have imposed one of the
strongest constraints I think we have
done on the on on the UK's
um powers in that regard and I think we
think that reflects the appropriate
balance of what how and uh how and in
what circumstances Minister should be
constrained and that means that they are
precluded from agreeing to a rule where
there is an across Community vote in
favor as the Secretary of State made
clear they are precluded uh and they can
only do so if they are if they consider
and these are factors they need to set
out to Parliament they're accountable to
Parliament for so doing well they think
it doesn't impose regulatory Borders or
they consider exceptional circumstances
uh I think that reflects the the fact
that as as the secretary they make clear
there may be exceptional circumstances
that
um would Merit the adoption of the rule
and I think we consider we've provided
the right balance of strong safeguards
and respecting the the ultimate role of
the UK government
doesn't feature as a standalone
consideration when exercising the vote
in the Joint Committee but for the
importance of parliamentary
interpretation and potentially
subsequent legal interpretation can I
ask you Secretary of State whether you
are satisfied that the threat of
remedial action from the European Union
would not constitute an exceptional
circumstance yes
under your officials concur
I'm not seeking to sort of provide
definitional elements here as to as to
what it means I think it's it's set out
in the SI and the household
um
Mr chairman that's why we're asking
so so I I think I've it's set out that
in the that there are exceptional
circumstances that set up the ministers
need to account for that uh to
Parliament and and those of that that's
it's codified that ministers must not
you have accepted secretary of state
that the threat of remedial action from
the European Union is not an exceptional
circumstances in the confines of article
or paragraph I I can't believe it could
be well I would say the proof of the
pudding is going to be an easy isn't it
so now if I could pass to Marcus fish uh
thanks I've I've got a set of questions
about the operation of the storm break
but just just on that remedial measures
issue I'm just interested actually how
and to what extent
um are the remedial measures that the EU
might take uh restricted uh other than
through what we were just discussing
versus what was there in the nip yeah I
mean so firstly they have to be
proportionate secondly they have to
apply to essentially non-line du trade
not UK
um EU
trade and there's a whole host of other
areas of clarification that I can write
to you and give
well I understand yeah
the the remedial measures sometimes the
word before in the treaty gets dropped
that they have to be appropriate and so
they would have to be proportionality
would hang off that
um obviously the UK itself would have
the rights to challenge that through
normal independent International
arbitration I think the alternative
um scenario that you talked about I
think the problem there and it would
have to be proportionate to the relevant
rule that had been uh vetoed which is
which is obviously becomes by its nature
much more restrictive I think the
challenge with the alternative scenario
particularly because of the the the the
interlinkages between the trade and
cooperation agreement and the withdrawal
agreement where there was sort of cross
retaliatory Provisions between the two
separate treaties uh meant that breaches
oh breaches of the withdrawal agreement
which which The veto under article 134
is not it's an envisaged veto now
strengthened significantly by the break
breaches do would give the EU the
ability to take much broader retaliatory
measures across the whole swathe of uh
uku trade as the Secretary of State set
out so basically organizations affect
Northern Ireland businesses and
businesses across the UK whereas the the
13-4 appropriate remedial measures is a
much
tighter context-specific scenario
specific
um uh situation and where the UK has our
own rights to challenge life it's done
in a disproportionate way and just one
extra point if I made just one sentence
um that there's a contrast here between
the winter framework and the Northern
Ireland protocol bill because that bill
would have given the EU the ability to
Levy tariffs on all trade
mm-hmm yeah
so um the command paper says that the
installment break is not subject to the
oversight of the court of justice and
any dispute would be resolved through
arbitration applying international law
are you confident that there are no
circumstances in which the court of
justice would be involved what for
example would happen if the arbitration
panel considered that the dispute
involved a question of EU law say the
arbitration panel took the view that the
question of whether a replacement EU Act
was significantly different from the one
it replaced was a matter of EU law and
to what extent does the fact of the
Quantum of harm to Northern Ireland and
Northern Ireland trade having been
identified by 30 mlas prior to that to
what extent is that within scope of the
arbitration panel to look at overriding
such questions or Vu law significance I
mean that is why it's it goes to the
arbitration panel and not to the
European judges the whole point of this
is that
um this is all under uh and please
correct me if I'm wrong this is all
under um strand one type territory of
the Belfast Good Friday agreement this
is uh this is a domestic
um Edition uh which we are enacting it's
down to us to uh to enact this it's been
accepted by the European Union as a uh
as a as a process
and I just think um
I mean to me when if something got to
the arbitration panel it would it would
be a very it would be an interesting
demonstration that this is actually
worked
um because that would have meant that we
would have uh gone through the process
the break would have been applied the
the measure would have been
uh put aside by The Joint Committee and
then the EU would have said that's not
it's just not correct and um and that
would be I think a pretty good
demonstration that the break does what
it says on the tin
and I think it would do what it says on
the tin because it is
it is a new Democratic Safeguard
inserted at the heart of the treaty and
um I haven't used many quotes yet today
Mr chairman but there's one from um one
of Michelle barnier's top advisors
who who said that the break it does
amount to a clear veto possibility for
the UK government directive by directive
at the behest of a minority in the
Northern Ireland assembly
and the arbitration mechanism
does not have to reflect ECG but could I
just ask this question so you're stating
to go back to what Marcus fish asks just
now that there are no circumstances in
which the court of justice would be
involved you confirming that I believe
so yeah I mean the the condition for
instance that Mr Fish discusses is an
objective condition set out in Article
13 in article 1338 that is not covered
by ecj's jurisdictions that should be a
judgment of fact for the arbitration
panel to reach so our view is that there
is no role for the ecga in the operation
of the storm break either during it or
during any period or any press of the EU
challenge you get I think the EU and its
own materials have acknowledged the
point that it's a matter for the ecj so
um that is you know that's the base on
which we're operating and that's
certainly our view that is your view and
the question which I put to you is is it
of interest to you if people put forward
another proposition which says the court
of justice would be involved in certain
circumstances that wouldn't be the
government's view we do not consider
that it does happen what you've said so
we'll now move on to the next question
well yeah yes of course my um my final
question is in the area of Ni
manufacturing and what it can or can't
do to GB standards
um uh because
um as I see it at the moment what the
Windsor framework proposes is
essentially that ni manufacturing
remains under the auspices of of EU law
and standards for manufacturing which is
what you referred to before Secretary of
State as being a thing which Northern
Ireland businesses wanted but I wondered
to what extent the government was
committed to looking at the evolution of
that position so that it may if for
example it is shown through this process
of Green Lane that in fact there are
robust mechanisms for ensuring that the
EU can be confident that goods are not
moving into their uh territory that in
fact Northern Ireland businesses might
be able in the future to uh to to have
an option to manufacture to
UK standards and law and therefore
participate properly in the internal
market supply chains back and forth from
GB that could let them take advantage of
for example future trade deals that we
might do with cptpp or the US and I just
wondered how committed is the government
to to evolving this in the future and
really championing Northern Ireland
Manufacturing in in that way yeah I mean
and
Mr Fish is an expert on these matters
and we've had many a conversation about
this um in the past
um the the one thing I'd say about the
manufacturing standards piece is that
most of these
all of these pretty much or those that
have standards are international
standards that both the EU and the UK
subscribe to
um I believe we have diverged
um out with 3 600 odd of these
International manufacturing standards we
we have diverged
um in I think it is 11 of them since
um
uh in in in recent time and
um but we have both the UK and the
European Union have agreed in the TCA to
follow International standards so we're
talking about we're talking about
slightly
different thing that's a slightly
different thing to what I was more
asking about because at the moment Goods
Goods have to
take take account of different rules of
origin when when they're passing back
and forth in to the you in into GB and
out to Northern Ireland so they they are
potentially subject to customs controls
of one kind or another and as a result
can't quite participate yet maybe
there's scope in the future and I I
would like to hear the government uh
commit to that because I think that
that's going to be important for the
future of the UK Union and for Northern
Ireland
yeah I think it's on the rules of origin
piece it's important to explain that the
um on the advantages of the Green Lane
and the way it'll operate under the
Joint Committee uh agreement within the
Windsor framework is that it won't for
these gbni Green Lane movements the
rules of origin won't matter for for the
for the movement you know there won't
there isn't any looking behind that the
only the question is obviously you have
to initially be authorized or in the
trusted Trader scheme and you have to
show that your good is for final
consumption and sale and use in Northern
Ireland but it doesn't matter that the
the good may have originally come from
the rest of the world into GB unlike a
sort of normal uh like if you were for
example hollyhead to Dublin where you'd
have to have to claim tariff status you
would need to have your rules of origin
certificate it would depend on the rules
of Origins to whether you could claim
that that won't be relevant for the
operation of the green line scheme
between GB and but um but you put your
finger on it when you said that the
Green Lane is only open to things that
are destined for fine consumption in Ni
rather than being then available for
incorporation in into a supply chain
that goes back into GB for example for
re-export so that there's a sort of a
kind of a processing function in
Northern Ireland that they can't take
advantage of the Green Lane yet maybe I
hope that that can change in the future
I don't know what you think
yeah the role there are um you know it
can because we manage within the Windsor
framework it expands the even for
processing where the good is being sort
of transformed in Northern Ireland there
are still the provisions now in the
winter framework that deal with those
scenarios as well for example if we
could move on I think David Jones got
the next question
yes thank you chairman
um you'll recall secretary of state that
the command paper said that the Windsor
framework would reduce uh as it put in
the rather narrow the range of EU rules
applicable in Northern Ireland to less
than three percent overall by the eu's
own calculations and when the Prime
Minister made his statement to the house
on the 27th of February I asked him if
he would kindly provide a list of those
uh rules so that the house could assess
its impact
um prime minister replied that he was
happy to look at that and then he went
on to say that he thought that the list
already existed
um
we haven't actually seen the list uh
despite this committee having twice
requested it
and similarly uh I tabled a written
question uh requesting that list and
didn't receive it I just had the
obfuscation that is sadly so common when
one raises written questions it wasn't
your department it was to the foreign
Commonwealth and development office
um you should always ask for my
department first is this such a list um
well let me so
on the claim we've actually heard on the
side of caution in terms of how we
sought to calculate the effect of these
changes but it's not it generally isn't
as simple as one list because some rules
are disapplied for the Green Lane and
support of internal UK trade and some
apply in the red lane but it is clear in
the text that there are sways of areas
where e-rules do not apply internal UK
trade
which safeguards an organized place in
our Union UK food and drink safety rules
applying on agri-food retail trade UK
wide licensing of medicines I've done by
UK authorities apply allowing plants to
move on the basis of a UK wide passport
scheme removing burden some customs
bureaucracy including all decorations
for Consumer parcel movements enabling
zero rates on vat for heat pump solar
panels and delivering on our alcohol
Duty changes across the whole world
food and drink there are 65 it just
applies for the 65 core regulations
through Annex one of the SPs legal texts
and I have the list
um
I will and as I say it's not as simple
as a one list but I will send you the
very a very long list
um
we asked for areas of this the the the
expression uh used is is rather curious
it Narrows the range of EU rules it
doesn't say it reduces the number of EU
rules
um and then it refers to three percent
overall three percent of what
law that applied through the northern
Ireland's 97 of EU law has been
swept away is that right it's disapplied
so that's um we're left with three
percent which is obviously a small
proportion so you will kindly provide us
with with a list of those or at least
let us have an explanation
um
also there was the reference to the 1700
pages of EU law which I think you
conceded was an unusual expression
because it depended on the size of the
font yeah I'm sure we can make it a lot
more if you wanted well yes but but
again I've actually asked for
for details of those and I haven't had
them is there any difficulty in in
providing those
um
I honestly I I don't think so is a
simple answer I mean it's a lot of paper
um in the just just to give you an
example of one of the pages I just
wanted a list okay fair enough but but
just if I may just give you one brief
example as to why through Alex one of
the SPs legal texts which displays the
65 core e-regulations
um uh implementing and implementing acts
that flow from them that covers over a
thousand pages of food safety commercial
protect consumer protection rules that
includes marketing standards from
sardines to Wine food supplements and
additives vitamins and minerals in food
as well as nutrition and health claims
GMOs and precision beading the
production of wine honey and natural
mineral Waters production of organic
good products and then there's a whole
piece about certification and there's a
whole piece about prohibitions but I
will happily you'll clearly you know so
I'm going to send you what I've got if
you don't mind if I send you what I have
and then direct you I'd rather not send
you the Thousand pages of food what was
the difficulty in providing the list
when we asked absolutely no idea okay
um one other point
um
Mr Smith uh raised the issue of
parliament having it say which was
promised by the Prime Minister on the
27th of February
um
is there going to be the sort of debate
that everybody assumed that that would
be in other words say a full-nosed
debate on the floor of the house when
the whole issue of the framework can can
be discussed by by members I also don't
know I mean that is for the Prime
Minister and the Parliamentary business
managers but I very much hope so
I mean it's going to be rather late in
the day because there's going to be the
ground signing on Friday with Mr Chef
jovic president isn't that um there's
going to be the joint committee on
Friday so by that stage really the bird
will have flown weren't it
um
no I I think
as I said earlier in my time as Chief
Parliament always manages to find a way
in having it say
um other huge amount of time is there if
this is happening on Friday I I right
this is part of the process which we're
going through now just for clarification
just to repeat
the vote tomorrow on the SI
is not intended to imply parliament's
approval of the Westminster framework as
a whole is that right uh no it's not
intended it's a vote on a stat Street
instrument
um which um
which I will say in my speech
um that this is this is a vote on a
statutory instrument
um on the Stormont uh break
which I think is actually I mean it's
what I I think you can say it's a it's a
vote on The Windsor framework as it
affects
um people I mean I think people are
taking it as that vote whether it is or
not is probably down it's all in the
eyes of the beholder what does the
government intended to to be and my my
intention is a vote on the answer it's a
discrete vote on one element of the
framework and not the framework as a
whole is that so number 10 I've said it
is yeah I think the position I think the
position is that the uh the the debate
and the instrument is on the storm on
break but obviously we wouldn't be able
to proceed with the joint committee on
Friday if the house didn't
um I didn't approve that so it was
important that we had a moment in in the
house before in advance The Joint
Committee which obviously formally
changes the treaty it's not actually
strictly necessary to do that because
the parliament's already given ministers
the power to change the treaty within
the joint committee and chose to do that
as part of the withdrawal agreements
I think as as uh down extreme stuff out
that you know it will be a say it's
impossible to it was not possible to
move forward with the Joint Committee
um on Friday without the House's
approval to the storm breaks as a
central change to the treaty and
there'll be a series of other domestic
instruments coming down the track
appreciate that but just for
clarification are you telling this
committee that the Downing Street
intends that the vote tomorrow shall be
Parliament say effectively on the
Windsor framework as a whole so I think
it's Parliament say on the on this on
the Sasha instrument as set out for the
storm will break what what does Downing
Street say well yeah as I say this they
you know it's it's uh it's a debate and
vote on this on the such instrument but
number 10 have said that
um that will be uh that will be taken as
a an overall say on the Windsor
framework itself because without that it
would be impossible for us to move
forward with the it is
forgive me so so that that's that's
Downing Street's intention so Parliament
having its say will comprise 90 minutes
debate on a single statutory instrument
and number 10 will be saying that that
is approval of the Windsor framework as
a whole is that do I understand that
correctly I think it's important to say
that won't be uh that will not be the
final moment of parliamentary scrutiny
and say because we'll need as we've set
out I think there'll be an extensive
program it's the same the parliament's
already given ministers powers in
relation to the Joint Committee uh that
was set out the point of ratification
and domestic in primary legislation uh
what this is doing is bringing forward
an instrument to make sure that there is
a moment before we have the joint
committee on Friday and there'll be lots
of you know we're planning on
legislating uh hopefully vat cuts that
can take effect very quickly after the
joint committee and there'll be a
separate piece of legislation on those
so there'll be a series of
um quite an extensive series of
opportunities for scrutiny and
Vocational history of State you you said
that Parliament usually Finds Its way to
have it say
um
put it this way the government isn't
volunteering time a government time
to have a sort of full debate that I
think everybody anticipated there would
be on the framework and which we were
given to believe would be the case when
the Prime Minister made a statement on
the 27th of September well the summer
break is an integral part of what we are
it's a new novel procedure it's an
integral part of what we're trying
trying to achieve through in the whole
of the wind Windsor framework
and I guess I
I Parliament does always find its way
um to express its views um
I I'd like to think actually that the
stormbreakers is is something that's
generally worth voting for
um because essentially not voting for it
is all is by implication voting for the
continuation of automatic alignment of
EU laws without a save for the people of
Northern Ireland but
um it is it is important in the in the
um it's an important part that will be
discussed again on Friday at the Joint
Committee which is why I believe it's
been tabled for this time
thank you we have two questions left so
next if I could perhaps I think Mr
Robinson wanted to ask a follow-up on
that today quickly very quick Mr
chairman to clarify an answer given to
Mr Jones
um Secretary State you were asked three
percent of what uh and you indicated
there was three percent of the laws that
applied under the Northern Ireland
protocol suggesting 97 of the laws under
the northern protocol have been
disapplied that can't be right can it
well the common agricultural policy are
you sure it's not 30 of EU law overall
overall nothing to do with the Northern
Ireland protocol through the northern
line protocol thank you thank you and Mr
Drax you wanted to ask her quick it's
just very quickly
um so I said you you kept saying uh we
all voted for this as if we're all in
this together and it's all our fault
that we're in the situation uh can I
just remind you would you not agree that
the protocol is based on the fact that
we would then negotiate quote with best
endeavor
best endeavor to make to find a way
forward the United Kingdom has for years
since the brexit of eight used every
single tool in the Box
to try and move forward and now after
negotiation behind closed doors were
even more trapped on Northern Ireland is
and the United Kingdom in the Europe
than we were before whatever you say
the another protocol is still in place
slightly amended that's the truth of the
matter
the Northern Ireland protocol is still
in place and will be amended and is
being amended by The Windsor framework I
would say fundamentally you would I
would and those would disagree
now Mr Baron has arrived and I'm very
glad to ask him if he'd like to ask a
question that's kind of you okay I'll
just one very quick question my
apologies to everybody but I've been
participating in the budget debate uh as
a member of the treasury select
committee very briefly at Secretary of
State
um I may be in a minority when I say
this but I support the Windsor framework
um
my question to you is this
we do have to be pragmatic as brexiteers
do we not in moving this whole debate
forward
and we've got the access now to trade
that binds the United Kingdom but can I
put this suggestion to the Secretary of
State to you and that is
that whilst brexit was always something
more than just about trade it was about
sovereignty it was about controlling
immigration uh free trade agreements and
all the rest of it
Norman Island if we do get this through
the Windsor framework could stand up the
cusp of a double good whammy in the
sense that it will have access to the UK
Market as well as the EU single Market I
mean that could attract a lot of
windward investment couldn't it you may
have touched on it you may have not I
don't know but isn't that a lot of
potential opportunity that we should not
underestimate I would generally I I did
mention this earlier in
um this session
um but generally hand on heart I do
believe this will lead to Greater
prosperity in Northern Ireland which
strengthens Northern Ireland's place in
the Union as I said earlier the proof of
the pudding has really been anything on
that one uh Mr Holloway please thanks
very much
um does this solve or potentially
exacerbate Community divisions
and uh is there a further bite of the
Cherry available after this or is it is
this it yeah no so I mean I actually I'd
like to think what this has done what
the Windsor framework has done has
um set a new tone in the relationship
between the United Kingdom having left
the European Union and the European
Union itself there are elements
um I believe I'm not someone previously
I think on this committee has asked
about
um the uh grace period that's currently
in place for veterinary medicines we
need to negotiate that right so but what
about what about what about power
sharing what about oh yeah I was
watching a second part of your question
first please forgive me um and so that
but I do think that based on that better
setting in the EU UK relationship lots
more can be done between between us that
is positive for us both and positive and
all that and on power sharing
my as I said at the very beginning and
it is absolutely the case my primary
objective as secretary of state is to
get the um the Northern Ireland
executive and assembly up and running
because that is
integral to the um both for good
democratic practice for delivery of
Public Services in Northern Ireland and
I do believe that this Windsor framework
eliminates all the negative aspects of
the protocols it currently stands and
would have come in as these periods of
time Grace periods have been eliminated
which meant that one section one one one
community in Northern Ireland felt so
aggrieved that its politicians felt they
had to leave the Strand one institution
and I do believe this goes some way to
solving that issue
I mean it clearly has it in some way but
I mean it still goes uh you've still got
the dep
not there I mean it hasn't solved
anything well that's it I mean so I
believe the leader of the dep was saying
he um what he said yesterday talked
about the progress that has been made
and I believe we have made a great deal
of progress and it's actually now
um it's down to the political leaders
and and parties in Northern Ireland to
look at look at this which is why we are
giving people the time and the space to
examine what it does could I just ask
Kevin Robinson if you'd like to just
comment on that please
[Laughter]
seat Mr chairman if that's what people
so wish
otherwise
the question was whether or not this
will fit on that no sorry
it's not for me to answer a question
like that in this session Mr John so you
have to say this tomorrow we were
presented with a singular proposition on
the storm and break which now manifests
itself into a global choice on the
Windsor framework which does not and is
not honoring the commitments to give
time and space to assess the totality of
issues associated with what the
government have provided well I think on
that point I think I have to complete
this session today thank you very much
Secretary of State for coming thank you
and um no doubt we'll be carrying on
this discussion into the indefinite
future thank you
maastrich two